what if we take a leap into the hard
problem of Consciousness the so-called
hard problem of Consciousness so it's
not just sort of self-awareness
it's this weird fact I want to say that
it feels like something to experience
stuff it really feels like something to
experience stuff there's seems to be a
self-attached to the subjective
experience how important is that how
fundamental is that to The Human
Experience
is this just a little Quirk and sort of
the flip side of that do you think AI
systems can have some of that same Magic
the the scene that comes to mind is from
the movie Memento where he like it's
this absolutely stunning movie where
every black and white scene moves in the
forward Direction and every color scene
moves in the backward Direction
and they're sort of converging exactly
at a moment where you know the whole
movie's revealed and he describes the
lack of memory as always remembering
where you're heading but never
remembering you know where you just wear
and sort of this encapsulating the sort
of forward scenes on the vaccines but in
one of the scenes the scene starts as
he's running through a parking lot and
he's like oh I'm running why am I
running and then he sees another person
not running like beside him on the other
line of cars he's like oh I'm chasing
this guy and he turns towards him with a
guy shoots him he's like oh no he's
chasing me
so in a way I like to think of the brain
as constantly playing these kinds of
things where you're like you're walking
to the living room to pick something up
and you're realizing that you have no
idea what you wanted but you know
exactly where it was but you can't find
it so you go back to doing what you were
doing like oh of course I was looking
for this and you go back and you get it
and this whole concept of
you know we're very often sort of partly
aware of why we're doing things and you
know we can kind of run on autopilot for
a bunch of stuff and this whole concept
of sort of you know making these stories
for you know who we are and and what our
intents are
and again sort of you know trying to
pretend that we're kind of on top of
things so it's a narrative exact
generation procedure that we follow but
what about that there's also just like a
feeling to it it doesn't feel like
narrative generation yes the narrative
comes out of it but then it feels like
uh so there's this cake is delicious
right it feels delicious it tastes good
there's two there's two components to
that basically for a lot of these
cognitive tasks where we're kind of
motion planning and you know path
planning Etc like you know maybe that's
the neocortical component and then for
you know I don't know uh Intimate
Relationships for food for you know
sleep and rest for exercise for
overcoming obstacles for surviving a
crash or sort of pushing yourself to an
extreme and sort of making it I think a
lot of these things are sort of deeper
down and maybe not yet captured by these
language models and that's sort of what
I'm trying to get at but I'm basically
saying listen there's a few things that
are missing and there's like this whole
embodied intelligence it's called
emotional intelligence this whole sort
of baggage of feelings of subcortical
regions Etc
I wonder how important that baggage is I
just have this suspicion that
we're not very far away from
AI systems that not only behave
I don't even know how to phrase it but
they seem awfully conscious they they
beg you not to turn them off
they
don't they show signs of the the
capacity to suffer to feel pain to feel
loneliness to feel longing
to feel that richly the experience of a
of a mundane interaction or a beautiful
uh once in a lifetime interaction all of
it and so what do we what do we do with
it I worry that us humans will
you know shut that off and uh and
discriminate against the the capacity of
another entity that's not human to feel
I'm with you completely there you know
we can debate whether it's today systems
or in 10 years or in 50 years but that
moment will come and ethically I think
we need to Grapple with it we need to
basically say that humans have always
shown this extremely self-serving
approach to everything around them
basically you know we kill the planet we
kill animals we kill you know everything
around us just do our own service
and um maybe we shouldn't think of AI as
our tool and as our assistant maybe we
should really think of it as our
children
and the same way that
you are responsible for training those
children but they are independent human
beings and at some point they will
surpass you and they will sort of go off
and
change the world on their own terms and
the same way that my academic children
sort of again you know they start out by
emulating me and then they surpass me
um we need we need to sort of think
about not just alignment
but also
just the ethics of
you know AI should have its own right
and uh this whole concept of alignment
of basically making sure that the AI is
always at the service of humans is very
self-serving and very limiting If
instead you basically think about AI as
a partner
and AI as someone that shares your goals
but has freedom
I think a line alignment might be better
achieved so the concept of
let's let's basically convince the AI
that we're really like that our mission
is aligned
and
truly generally give it right and not
just say oh and by the way I'll shut you
down tomorrow because basically if that
future AI or possibly even the current
AI has these feelings then we can't just
simply force it to align with ourselves
and we not align with it
so in a way building trust is mutual you
can't just simply like train an
intelligent system to love you when it
realizes that you can just shut it off
people don't often talk about the AI
alignment problem as a two-way street
and maybe that's true yeah as it becomes
more and more intelligent
it uh
it will know that you don't love it back
yeah and there's a humbling aspect to
that that we may have to sacrifice as
any
any effective collaboration exactly it
might have some compromises yeah and uh
that's the thing we're creating
something that will one day be more
powerful than we are and for many many
aspects it is already more powerful than
we are for some of these capabilities
we cannot like think suppose that chims
had invented humans yes and they said
great humans are great but we're going
to make sure that they're aligned and
that they're only at the service of
chimps
it would be a very different planet we
would live in right now